my job for the next 15 minutes is to be
your tour guide through the history of
motion pictures focusing on the history
of the audience the experience of
exhibition and how film has connected
with other art forms as I do so the
major message I want to get across here
is the idea that the news of the death
of cinema has been greatly exaggerated
right that there are no dead media there
are dead delivery technologies they're
dead businesses they're dead they're
dead practices but once we introduce a
medium a mode of human expression
extension of the human sensorium into
the universe they tend to persist so
dramatic theater live theatre persist in
the face of cinema radio persists in the
face of television and so as we think
about what's happening in the future we
have to understand that what we see here
is the cinema as it's been experienced
by my son's generation right he's now in
his 30s and this is what cinema has been
for him but if we reify that and make
it's one thing a very fragile thing then
we then we don't know what to do with
the passing of that set of institutions
so what I want to suggest tonight is
that cinema has always been many things
there have been many spaces where films
have been rejected many experiences were
going to the movies many ways the
audience has participated in the
experience of movies and many different
connections between film and other media
platforms so as we think about the
future we need multiple histories
because we will have multiple futures so
we go back to the very beginnings of the
cinema what historians call the cinema
of attractions takes place across a
variety of different venues so if you're
middle-class living in Los Angeles at
the turn-of-the-century you might well
have seen cinema for the first time in a
vaudeville house alongside trained dog
acts baggy pants comedians opera singers
acrobats and people who've danced on
giant xylophones and in that contact
cinema was experienced as a series of
short spectacular moments not yet
stories not yet long form scarcely short
form
if you lived in the country you might
have experience cinema through a
traveling tent show and the exhibitor
there would also have been a master
showman would have projected the images
would have been the narrator the star
persona personality would have curated
the show would have edited the footage
together would have constructed the
stories you were consuming seeing out of
shots that were sold to him by various
film producers you might have Co seen a
movie for the first time in an amusement
park there were rides which consisted of
railroad cars or gondolas or balloons
that rocked back and forth and images
were projected to give you that sense of
motion and there might be steam pouring
into your face as you watch those motion
there's motion pictures so there was an
immersive experience of what movies
might have looked at the first movie
theaters were simply shop fronts adopted
quickly peanut shells on the floor where
people might go to to see a series of
short subjects the audience here is
mostly for mostly immigrant populations
mostly lower-class populations and it
would not be at all unusual for the ones
one person who spoke English to be
articulating to the crowd and a variety
of languages what they were watching
spontaneously from the audience so the
audience in the very beginning is part
of the show films only begin to become
features when we have ready-made
theaters when few theaters have their
own facilities where we can be
comfortably seating in that magic chair
and experience the film for a more
prolonged period of time and by the late
1920s film becomes part of something
bigger if you've been to the movie to my
own Street Broadway you can see
something like a dozen surviving our
movie palaces that are still there those
movie palaces would not only have shown
two feature films live entertainment
sing-alongs but would also of may be
included a nightclub a bowling alley a
daycare center a restaurant a barber
shop or beauty salon you went there for
the day and movies were part of that
overall experience and if we continue
thinking about
and movies could have been the drive-in
would have been another model by the
1950s as we began to move out to the
suburbs the open spaces and by the car
culture of La would have invited us to
go see movies outside and the privacy of
our own cars today we're still exploring
what other spaces can be used for movies
right so this is a dive-in movie not a
drive-in movie right we can think about
secret cinemas creating unique cinematic
experiences where movies are seen in
just the right space for that movie and
you have to be in the know to get there
and as we heard earlier we are seeing
movies projected on all kinds of
physical surfaces in the world around us
both authorized and unauthorised
screenings of movies create unique
experiences events that that people go
to the sea at the movies an event might
be something like the screening of Star
Wars at the Hollywood Dome where the
LA's symphonic orchestra playing playing
live accompaniment these are the kinds
of futures future events that will keep
people coming back to the cinema as a
unique experience again and again and
again the event brings with it a sense
of immersiveness so we can do the
history of the 50s and the competition
of television through a series of
technologies here we have Cinerama but
all of those technologies promises more
or less the same things today's
technologies promise to immerse us into
a cinematic experience of Cinerama puts
you into the picture brings you a whole
new world here we have a roma rama see
it hear it smell it and I think who
smelt it dealt it I'm not sure or little
later surround sound an event in 70
milliliters and surrounds and surround
see it hear it feel it we've seen 3d
come go come again but 3d is just the
beginning because around the world we're
now seeing 4d 5d 60 70 you got numbers
we'll keep putting DS after it and what
they're all promising are new kinds of
immersive
experiences of what a movie might be and
whoa dude that's just the beginning
right as we move into the world of
virtual reality the immersive experience
of cinema can begin yet again something
new and yet something that goes all the
way back to the Hales tours at the
amusement parks the turn of the century
and we take for granted that we can for
a long time we've taken for granted we
can see movies in other spaces on
airplanes in classrooms the 30s and 40s
they were already there in schools and
prisons on military bases movies always
went beyond the commercial movie theater
and even before we had motion pictures
we had home based technologies we're
amateurs could project stories in this
case the magic lantern in the late 19th
century we could talk about super 8
movies we can talk about view masters we
can talk about films tropes all
technologies which allowed the audience
to sample their favorite moments from
their favorite movies and to bring that
into the context of their home and all
of that looks toward the world of VHS
the world of DVD and now the world of
streaming video on our phones and other
appliances every time I go to the movies
these days I see them telling me you
don't want to watch a movie on a screen
that size but that's not the only
context where we're watching movies in
the context of our home and we now have
movie theater movie theaters in some
cases that are as sophisticated as those
multiplex screens were 30 years ago and
where those who are only going to get
better so as we think about cinema the
future of cinema will involve diverse
not singular exhibition experiences both
public and private both in commercial
movie theaters and beyond we will have
event movies that we all turn out to see
and we'll have movies that we will watch
when we have time and we're watched by
whatever device we have handy at the
time that movies available we may have
fewer event movies in the future but the
rust aside that a hundred years plus of
history of public exhibition of feature
films tells us we will always have movie
events suck in history history of star
fandom right so from the very beginning
of the silent era stars coexisted with
their fans
whether through fan letters autograph
lines fan clubs where people collected
and agreed to see it this is a connected
audience - right these people felt
connected to the star and connected
through each other through the social
networks they forged as fans in relation
to movies and the idea of participatory
culture we can take back to something
like the original Mickey Mouse clubs
that Disney organized in movie theaters
in the 20s and 30s which had Saturday
morning matinees crafts shows all kinds
of experiences which encourage people to
come back every week as a participant in
the experience of being a Disney movie
so the second Mickey Mouse Club was the
one that was produced on television in
the 1950s but the first ones worth
remembering the movie theater in the
movie that where that magic chair was
the movie Palace of the 20s and 30s also
would have been a space where people
sang along right follow the bouncing
ball so we were encouraged to be part of
the show there might be Amateur Night
performances we were not simply there to
be spectators we were there to be
participants and the idea of performing
the movie really reached at a point in
high day in the 70s and 80s with
midnight movies like Rocky Horror
Picture Show where people were
encouraged to come in costume dance in
the aisle three things at the screen and
this is a global phenomenon so if we go
to India say we would see Bollywood
dance as a central part of the
experience of what film means in India
if we go to Japan we see cosplay and
Yoyogi Park and Tokyo is one of the ways
in which people dressed up like their
favorite characters from anime films or
manga and really became part of the
phenomenon they were invested in and
here in California we certainly know
about the cosplay that takes place in
San Diego every summer where I get
together with 150,000 of my closest
friend friends and Hollywood comes and
puts on a show for us because we've all
got Twitter we've all got blogs we've
all got Facebook and we are part of the
publicity machine that Hollywood counts
on now to get the word out about
exciting fall and summer
but I'm from the very beginning we were
not simply want viewers of movies so
here are the Lumiere brothers most of
you know the history of movies know that
they are kind of the key an early moment
in history of cinema in almost every
country around the world why do we have
so many movies of people leaving
factories and getting off trains because
the lumières would come set up their
public their camera in a public place
film people and then pass out a flyer
saying come to the theater tonight you
can see your picture on the big screen
so as long as we've had movies we've had
amateurs participating in movies and
when they came time to build an army of
camera crews to travel the world
they went to amateur camera clubs across
Europe people who were already
experimenting with the technology and
they became the first wave of film
makers so the move from amateur to
professional was there from the very
beginning by the late silent period we
have fan films that are being produced
and we know well documented there were
lots of films made around the our gang
comedies because you an amateur
filmmaker dad could take his camera in
the backyard gather the kids in the
neighborhood and they could make an our
gang movie this is a cover of a magazine
1937 movie maker the magazine of the
amateur cinema league so by 1937 there
are enough amateur filmmakers in the
u.s. to have US public or have
organizations to have magazines by the
time I entered the picture in the 1960s
I'm part of this generation of movie
monster fans and the movie brats the
Spielberg's the Lucas's the Zemeckis is
the land this is the people whose names
are in the buildings at USC they grew up
reading Famous Monsters of Filmland
magazine and and therefore SK Ackerman
was encouraging us to try monster makeup
you know what it is to be a guy in the
60s and we playing with your mom's
makeup to see if you can look like
Dracula right super 8 movie cameras
models every possible way that we could
express ourselves through the language
of monster movies which were this and
out of that came a generation of them
the big blockbusters that have made
Hollywood what it is today
what's different perhaps was that those
were called home movies right they were
called home movies because they were
shot at home they were watched at home
and if we were lucky we got a neighbor
to pay 15 cents to buy a bag of popcorn
to watch our movies right today
home movies have become public movies
and the age of YouTube high school kids
are producing the same kinds of movies
putting them out on the web and they
become and the right moment one of them
can get a hundred thousand views right
can reach critical mass can go quote go
viral or as I prefer go spreadable right
so that moment today the people who are
making those movies are the future USC
students they are the future Lucas's
Spielberg's and and so forth but that's
only one of the ways the audience is
choosing to participate so fanfiction
hundreds of thousands of stories set
around every possible fictional universe
were you disappointed by a TV show
series book or film if you still love
your fandom discover fan fiction today
and have the story your away
and increasing the audience is
encouraged to be an investor to support
films that they care about and get films
made that might not have been made under
the studio system otherwise and I think
we're gonna see more and more examples
of crowdfunding filmmakers courting the
audience from the very conception of
their film so again the future film
audience will demand the right to
meaningfully participate in the cinema
experience I tell my students at USC we
live under the sign of Felix rights if
you've been to USC campus you've seen
this Felix the Cat sign on a car
dealership felix was one of the first
transmedia personalities he was in sheet
music he was in Broadway shows he was in
the comic strip
he was only animated on the big screen
and he was in valk aynd zuv brand
products across the culture this simply
is one of those examples of brand
extension that survived throughout the
20th century and is still with us today
chaplin was in comic strips many of the
stars i grew up in in the 50s and 60s
had their own comic books where there
was Jerry Lewis or Three Stooges that
was just the beginning of the print
culture that surrounds the film of the
day film was never simply the movie film
was always part of a collage of media
experiences so the star system depended
on movie magazines depended on
collectibles these are cigarette cards
the predate bubble gum cards
that were the collectibles of the star
system of the early of the 20s and 30s
and stars would leave Hollywood go to
various towns and cities across America
and Rory Rogers Dale Evans and trigger
would suddenly step off the big screen
and be right there in your shopping
centre I remember seeing one of the
Munchkins from Wizard of Oz when I was a
kid and it's an experience I carried
with me forever after beyond that radio
had a number of series which performed
films even some films still in the
theater sometimes of the original cast
sometimes with other cast members and
part of the pleasure of listening to
deluxe radio theater is seeing classic
parts and classic films played by
different Hollywood stars little big
books takes the story we saw on the
screen and extended it in new directions
and of course locate Disney takes that
the next step to location-based
experiences so we can ride the movies
that we're invested that we become
invested in and Disney gave us the tools
the costumes the props so we can perform
those movies that were part of our
fantasy life as kids Lucas takes that
greed gives us the avatars the action
figures and Star Wars if we think about
some of the characters like Boba Fett
and Star Wars they were built not on the
big screen but in people's backyards as
people played Boba Fett invested the
character and he became a cash cow for
the Lucasfilm Empire or even talking
about making a full-on bow bow that
movie and this next wave of Star Wars
productions so all of the same Hollywood
has always been not simply a movie but a
transmedia experience and I wrote in my
book convergence culture about the
matrix as not only three films but also
a series of animated shorts a series of
comic stories a series of video games
all of which are interconnected and
information travels freely across them
each makes their unique contribution to
the experience as a whole and that's
today transmedia has become a buzzword
in the industry and we're seeing it
everywhere from park benches these are
the park benches created around district
9 when the film came out and we saw lots
of those here in Los Angeles to the web
and bent bullet is a
see theory side about how the x-men
killed JFK
and that's the TED talk from Prometheus
both examples are very compelling
digital content that spread create
awareness of those films and were part
of the overall experience
so if we want to think about the future
cinema it will be a transmedia
phenomenon as it has been in the past
we're storytelling extending across
every available media platform so if I'm
asked what's the future of film going
it's going to be film is going to be
experienced in multiple venues as an
event and as an everyday activity that
film is going to be something we
participate in that we help create as
well as simply something we watch and
film will be transmedia
a driver of entertainment experiences we
have across media platforms so thank you